Avengers infinity war is a game changer
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
the movies post-credits scene is crucial
to a complete understanding of its
cliffhanger ending UPK movie lovers it's
Jan here and today I'm breaking down the
end credits scene to reveal what it
means Easter eggs and how it sets up
Avengers 4 I'm also kicking off a new
Avengers giveaway so make sure you're a
subscriber and leave a comment about the
movie to enter I should expect spoilers
ahead for Avengers infinity war the post
credits scene starts with Nick Fury and
Maria Hill driving through New York fury
asks Hill if there's any word from Tony
Stark but although Hill is monitoring
satellites worldwide she's not picking
up anything as Starks on Titan Hill does
get a signal though for multiple
unidentified crafts over Wakanda that
have an energy signature 10 times those
seen during the Chitauri invasion of New
York fury that mentions a name which
sounds like Cline or Clint but he gets
cut off as a car swerves out of control
in front of them as hill and fury check
the car that crashed they find the
driver's seat is empty because the
driver has disintegrated a helicopter
then smashes into a Manhattan skyscraper
again because the pilot has vanished and
fury tells Hill to call control Code Red
but Maria Hill starts to fade into ash
and people in the street also start to
disappear fury runs to his car grabs the
device and as he activates it he also
starts to evaporate into dust the device
falls to the ground but blinks a message
sending for a few seconds before coming
up with Captain Marvel's emblem so this
is a pretty crucial scene as it shows a
snap event that Thanos initiated is
already happening on a global level at
the end of the movie we saw the snap
wipe out around half of the heroes
assembled in Wakanda and on Titan but
this extra scene shows that it's now a
wider event with Thanos fulfilling his
goal of wiping out half of all living
beings in the cosmos this is a pretty
desperate situation and on the surface
it seems a rather bleak ending to the
movie however that final shot of Captain
Marvel's logo brings a much-needed ray
of hope and the introduction of Captain
Marvel will be essential to how our
surviving heroes will try to take
downtown
Avengers for Marvel Studios head honcho
Kevin Feige said that Captain Marvel
will be the most powerful character
they've ever put in a movie
her powers are off the charts and when
she's introduced she'll be by far the
strongest character we've ever had
before she arrives in Avengers 4 though
Captain Marvel played by brie Larson
will be debuting as Carol Danvers in her
own solo movie we'll get to see exactly
why she's so important in the MCU
danvers first appeared in Marvel Comics
in 1968 and obtained her powers when
during an accident her DNA bonded with
that of Marvel a Kree a lien Carol
Danvers has an incredible variety of
powers ranging from superhuman strength
to spaceflight plus energy absorption
and projection among others brie Larson
has said that Captain Marvel is a
believer in truth and justice and is a
bridge between Earth and space and that
means she's key to fixing the ending of
Avengers infinity war where there are
just two surviving groups of heroes in
Wakanda we've got Captain America Black
Widow Bruce Banner war machine Rocket
Raccoon Akoya and mbaku and on Titan
there's just Iron Man and nebula as the
Shuri Wang and Pepper Potts they're fake
during the snap event is for the moment
unknown revenge is for the heroes who
are separated we'll need to band
together and I can see that Carol
Danvers being a bridge between Earth and
space could be able to make this happen
by the way it's interesting that the
movie begins and ends with a distress
signal it was the Asgardians under
attack from Thanos and now it's fury to
Captain Marvel regards to Nick Fury it's
obviously pretty heartbreaking to see
both him and Maria Hill just fade to ash
in this scene but it's a really striking
way of showing the universal and
devastating effect of Thanos is snap
that moment has made even more poignant
coming as it does in a film that
celebrates the 10th anniversary of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because after
all it was Nick Fury who appeared in the
very first Marvel Studios post credit
scene at the end of Iron Man I you think
you're the only superhero in the world
mr. stark you've become part of a bigger
universe you just don't
who the hell are you Nick Fury director
of shield
I'm here to talk to you about the
Avenger initiative axis samuel l.jackson
has been cast in the Captain Marvel
movie which will also explore Fury's
origins and very likely what led him to
the Avenger initiative it's set in the
1990s where we'll meet Nick Fury at a
time before he lost an eye
talking about Fury's role in the film
Kevin Feige has said that Fury has
reached a point in his career where he
thought the Cold War is over and the
best days are behind him and when he
encounters certain things in this movie
it sets him on a path that leads us to
where we are 19 films later looking at
the device Fury used to contact Danvers
I thought it seemed a bit dated in terms
of tech which made me suspect it might
have been designed in the 90s and so
it's quite possible we'll see it in the
Captain Marvel movie another possible
Hat's hip in the post-credits scene is
to a moment in Captain America the
Winter Soldier
spoiler ahead if you haven't seen the
Winter Soldier in that movie fury had to
silently spell out a message to Steve
Rogers to let him know that shield had
been compromised in both films fury is
warning another superhero of a threat
and just as he does the former shield
director is killed or at least he
appeared to die in the Winter Soldier
because later it's revealed that the
death was a fake out and I suspect that
Fury's death in this post-credit scene
could well be reversed in Avengers for
something that will need to be addressed
in the Captain Marvel movie is why Nick
Fury never contacted Carol Danvers until
now for help after all there have been
some global threat level events like the
Chitauri invasion of New York in the
first Avengers film and then there were
the events in sokovia in age of Ultron
it's possible that as serious as those
incidents were fury felt comfortable
enough that the Avengers could contain
those threats
however in infinity war the threat is
clearly massively larger with Maria hill
saying the energy signatures of the
invaders overwork and ER were 10 times
bigger than those recorded during the
Battle of New York with Tony Stark and
available and people literally vanishing
in front of Fury's eyes it's likely that
all this is why Fury hit that Captain
Marvel distress call now by the way Nick
Fury's mother was of course a joke about
samuel l.jackson sick
a curse word and him finally getting to
almost say it in the MCU but I wonder if
it's also a little wink to age of Ultron
when fury skulls cap about his language
he's dusty but she'll do Fury's
son-of-a-bitch oh you kiss your mother
with that mouth we also need to talk
about the name that fury drops just
before the car crashes in front of him
and Maria hill Fury's line isn't totally
clear and sounds a bit like he's saying
tell Clint meaning that he's trying to
get in touch with Clint Barton aka
Hawkeye but if you listen really
carefully he actually says tell Klein to
meet just before he gets cut off Klein
refers to Cameron Kline the former
shield tech who refused to launch the
insight helicarriers in Captain America
the Winter Soldier Klein also had a
brief cameo in age of Ultron where he'll
of fury saved him from one of Ultron's
BOTS interestingly in the comics Clyde
has worked alongside Captain America and
his grandfather was saved by cap during
World War two and I wonder where the
Kleins name-drop in the post credits
scene means we'll see this tech
specialist reappear in Avengers 4 to
help the Avengers pick up the pieces of
the snap aftermath another little thing
to look out for in this scene is a model
of the car hill and fury are driving
suitably enough it's a Nissan Infiniti
which has already featured in an
infinity war related promo
now you may still have a lot of
questions about how the snap and
infinity wars cliffhanger ending is
going to be resolved and I go into lots
more detail about that in my ending
explained video I'll add a link to tap
here and in the video description below
as soon as that's live so what are your
thoughts on the end credits scene and
the Captain Marvel teased leave me a
comment and subscribe to enter my new
avengers Funko pop giveaway the winner
of my last Marvel giveaway is on screen
now so send me a private message with
your details if that's you tapleft for
my infinity war ending explained video
and tap write for my full Marvel
playlists with Easter eggs theories and
deleted scenes thanks for watching and
see you next time you became movie
lovers